kelly the season ends with quite the
shock and i don't even know if you know
this andrew shows up to anna's house
unannounced were you aware of this
now i am
who is it
true
kelly's andrew what's he doing here
hello
oh there you are how you doing anna
what happens next what's your
relationship with andrew like now
um
well
i
wouldn't say that there is a
relationship
but i will say that everybody makes
mistakes
everybody
judges people
choose quickly sometimes
and on when i look back at this whole
first season and i i thought about it
there were certain things that just
really bothered me that didn't make
sense when we went to europe or paris
there's so many things so was it
contrived was it
i don't know did they want to fight i
don't know however i just think that
you know nobody's perfect and everybody
makes mistakes and everybody should be
given a second chance
and then we'll see what happens all
right so maybe some resolution from
lingering stuff season three sounds
quite promising if we get one hopefully
what's your reaction to him resurfacing
after a season of watching you
try and find yourself again after the
end of that relationship i can't control
him and then i think that if anna and
him want to be friends they can and um
but for me like i think we've already
set our piece and uh you know i wish
nothing but the best
so there's no
chance that that goes
anywhere again if we get the next season
we'll see
[Music]
you